6 Monate Knast das hat Boris Becker
jetzt schon mal geschafft immerhin seit
Ende April sitzt er ja im Gefängnis er
wurde zu zweieinhalb Jahren verurteilt
ja und jetzt die erste Nachricht
sozusagen wieder aus Boris Knast und die
geht an Bild also wir erfahren jetzt wie
geht's ihm wirklich den Boris Becker
nach all der Zeit im Knast und das weiß
unsere bild-show-chefin Tanja mai bei
uns im Studio grüße dich herzlich Tanja
also ganz einfache Frage wie geht's
Boris es geht ihm wirklich den Umständen
entsprechend gut also er hat sich
eingefügt in diesen Gefängnisalltag der
sicher ja nicht Alpha ist für jemand der
ist gewohnt es um die ganze Welt zu
reisen dann plötzlich bist du
eingesperrt und musst dich eben an
gewisse Regeln halten aber wir haben mit
seinem Anwalt gesprochen und auch mit
seinem engsten Umfeld er hat sich
eingefügt er hat abgenommen natürlich
das ist glaube ich auch klar natürlich
die gefängniskost auch mag sie noch so
gut sein ist auch nicht vergleichbar mit
dem was du ja im Freien leben zu dir
nehmen kannst er macht viel Sport und
was ich sehr bemerkenswert finde er ist
er ist so eine Art assistenzlehrer des
eigentlichen Coaches also sich vor allem
auch und die Psychologie um die Fitness
kümmert der Häftlinge das sind ungefähr
45 Häftlinge die auch von Bordes mit
unterrichtet werden geht es auch um Yoga
und ja und vor allem um die Bewältigung
von Lebens das heißt er hat jetzt auch
tatsächlich eine Aufgabe im Knast
gefunden ja klar auf jeden Fall also er
hat das bestmögliche natürlich gemacht
was er machen kann er ist
Spitzensportler er kennt sich mit Sieg
und Niederlagen aus er kennt sich mit
Lebenskrisen aus und all diese
Ratschläge kann er natürlich jetzt an
die Häftlinge geben und wie man hört
sind die sehr dankbar dafür dass sie von
Boris Becker gecoacht werden
jetzt nach all der Zeit gehört habt das
ist sozusagen die erste Nachricht jetzt
wieder aus dem Boris Knast exklusiv von
euch recherchiert auch eben über Boris
deutschen Anwalt wenn du all das jetzt
zusammensetzt macht dir das eher noch
mehr Sorgen um Boris oder kannst Du
eigentlich sagen na gut jetzt ist eine
große Zeit schon geschafft er ist
eigentlich auch ein ganz guten Weg also
ich war ja von Anfang an der Meinung so
schlimm dieses Urteil natürlich gewesen
sein muss für Bordes Bäcker aber ich bin
nach wie vor davon überzeugt er wird als
ein stärkerer Mensch auf jeden Fall
rauskommen wenn irgendwann die
Haftstrafe verbüßt verbüßt ist ich denke
er wird demütiger sein und dankbarer und
weiß auch gewisse Dinge wieder richtig
einzuordnen und zu schätzen als von
daher glaube ich so schlimm die
Haftstrafe ist für Boris Becker ihm
konnte jetzt nichts besseres passieren
auch mal in sich zu gehen und auch zu
überlegen okay was will ich noch vom
Leben wie geht es weiter und ich bin mir
sicher er wird mit Plänen aus der
Haftstrafe rauskommen was hört man denn
von seiner Familie von seinen Kindern
besuchen die ihn regelmäßig also auf
jeden Fall seine Lebensgefährtin besucht
den regelmäßig aber er darf ja auch
telefonieren und er telefoniert
natürlich vor allem auch mit seinen
Söhnen mit seiner Lebensgefährtin mit
seiner Mutter und auch mit seiner extra
Barbara so also geht's Boris Becker nach
rund einem halben Jahr im Knast Center
Gefängnismauern das sagt unsere
bild-show-chefin Tanja mai danke dir
gerne
[Musik]